so
so let's let's move to uh today what
what times we're living in today we just
had the election and i know you
you were on tucker and a few different
shows and you
express your support for uh
trump and obviously the election happens
now we have a
biden as the president elect that many
say time magazine just came out last
week calling him president
of the united states number 46 cover-up
time magazine they did a special
and right now they're going through a
lot of different uh
uh issues and sidney powell you know
giuliani the lawyers are doing their
part to see what's going to happen with
michigan
uh how do you feel about what's gone on
with the election the last
few weeks so
just as an intro um as you mentioned you
know 33 years
and you know why i'm speaking out now uh
on
the us elections you know i came i came
out publicly about two months ago
a bit over two months ago and
it was really important for me to state
my beliefs
in terms of why president trump is such
a great president
and why we absolutely need four more
years
and i knew i was going to get an
immediate platform
simply because of the name that i carry
and
knowing myself and my character i know
that if i didn't speak up for what i
believe
i wouldn't be able to look at myself in
the mirror because we really
are at a crucial moment in time
where you know it's the tipping point
and
western civilization hangs in the ballot
right and
and for me president trump
is the man of the hour that can
you know keep us on the right direction
towards preserving our western values
and our
and our western ideals and our way of
life and our freedoms
right so this is why i decided to speak
up ahead of the elections and
specifically on the elections
and so coming back to the to today you
know we're the 18th of november
and um and two weeks has gone by
since the elections
it's astounding to me that
we are now speaking with world leaders
the mainstream media the biden camp
itself
former politicians you know who
former presidents who are still you know
working in the shadows
um pushing this narrative that joe biden
is president-elect
he is not and here in europe everybody
believes it
because they don't really know about you
know the us
constitution and the election process
and
you know they are being misled by the
egregious gaslighting campaign of the
mainstream media to believe this lie
when in fact none of the states have
certified
the votes and this is still very much a
question
right so joe biden first of all is not
yet
or in my opinion will not be president
elect the the proofs of
fraud in
so many states is rampant and
you know keeps keeps coming and is
overflowing and until
this is sorted out um we owe
the american voter and
america in general you know the
preservation
of its constitution and of its electoral
system
who and why you know it it says a lot
you know that
the democrat party is willing to just
ram this train through on the tracks i
mean it's in the interest of everyone
isn't it to have fair and transparent
elections and if there is you know
indications of fraud both camps should
want
to explore this right but it doesn't fit
their narrative and their agenda
and the hypocrisy of it all patrick you
know looking at these people
whether it's as i said the politicians
and
you know the oligarchs and the
stakeholders in this
and the media and the journalists you
know the blue check
twitter people um who
for four years undermined and questioned
the legitimacy
of the trump presidency now
won't even give for four years on
through bogus hoaxes
that have been proven to be wrong now
won't even give the courtesy
to the american voter of exploring
these issues of fraud it's
to me this hypocrisy is quite sickening
to be frank
no why do you think 80 million people
according to ap associated press
why do you think 80 million americans
voted for biden and they disagree with
you
well first of all i don't believe that
number um
that's the first thing i mean how are we
supposed to believe
that a man who was hiding in his
basement for the whole year
who could barely um gather you know
50 people at rallies in concentric
circles compared to the images
of these magur valleys that happened all
across the country
with floods of um of trump's support
trump supporters gathering um to show
you know they are clearly behind
the president and they clearly want for
more years and the numbers just don't
add up you know when you look at you say
80 million
we're supposed to believe that this
candidate garnered
more votes than hillary clinton than
obama you know in the previous elections
and you add this you know to all the
other
elements of the voter voting fraud that
is emerging and as you said you know a
bit earlier there was the press
conference today with
rudy giuliani and sydney powell who is
doing such
both you know are doing such an
incredible job
at um at uh
you know exposing all of this but also
fighting so hard to preserve
america and its democracy right
and as i said there are many numbers
that don't add up there are many
practices you know
that don't add up we know that
republican republicans or you know the
people who oversee
the elections weren't allowed in the
rooms there are affidavits
of witnesses saying that you know voting
ballots were tampered with
there's just you know and then the big
one
the big question mark of all is what
happened with these voting systems you
know dominion voting system
smartmatic all of this
it smells really bad patrick what if
it's
if it's fraud if there is voter fraud
you have to trust this system to know
that it's going to expose it
and if it's voter fraud if sydney powell
and giuliani are
the lawyers that they are they're gonna
be able to
get to it and reveal it and if they do
reveal it
and we find out that there's voter fraud
trump becomes president
if not biden as president let's assume
they don't find anything let's assume
they don't find anything
and let's assume biden is president
what's your biggest concern about a
biden presidency
so first of all i have complete faith in
in this legal team
so um i'm very optimistic
but the hypothetical that you're putting
forward
i think it would be a disaster um
to have a biden harris presidency which
in reality would be a third um
obama term in all you know
logic we know that you know obama is the
first president who didn't leave
washington i think since
woodrow wilson it's normally common
courtesy for outgoing presidents to
leave washington d.c
and he is the first president in over
just under 100 years who didn't do that
and
when you look at his role and the role
that he's played you know in the past
four years behind the scenes
um most egregious of all with this
russia collusion hoax and what they did
to
lieutenant general flynn
[Music]
you clearly have bad actors
who for the past few years but we can go
even further back
but let's stick to the present you know
time frame but you clearly have
bad actors such as barack obama
who have been
working very hard at undermining
america's sovereignty and standing in
the world
the past few years and um looking you
know from
from afar because i'm not in america but
observing all of this
all play out and you know as you can see
behind me i have the epic times
brilliant um spy gate poster which i had
blown up and
put on my wall and i encourage all of
your viewers to go look at that
and also if they want to understand
really what transpired
with what they did to general flynn and
president trump with this hoax everybody
should watch the movie
the plot against the president which is
brilliantly made
you